[Music]
we have been looking at the counterfeit
of what Satan is doing to to counterfeit
what our Lord has promised in his word
we've been looking at spiritual
formation and it's Eastern mystical
roots and we're seeing how the enemy is
duplicating he's lying and deceiving and
through these Eastern arts he's
infiltrating the Christian Church I want
to open tonight
with a promise in Romans chapter 8 turn
with me there Romans chapter 8 verse 19
it says for the earnest expectation of
all creation is waiting for the
manifestation of the sons and daughters
of God that's what the entire universe
is waiting to see and that's the one
thing that Satan is seeking to
counterfeit tonight we are going to show
what he is doing and how this is coming
into our church mystery unveiled the
Omega of a most startling nature you
remember that in the very beginning I
asked you to make note of that word
nature we know that there's two
mysteries spoken of very prominently in
Scripture the first mystery that we see
is in 1st Thessalonians or 2nd
Thessalonians chapter 2 it says the
mystery of iniquity death already work
but in timothy paul tells timothy the
mystery of godliness is God manifest in
the flesh so what we have seen over the
last few messages
is that the mystery of iniquity is the
exact opposite of the mystery of
godliness instead of it being God
manifest in the flesh it is evil spirits
and demonic forces that are manifesting
in human flesh I'm going to open with a
statement from the Lord servant eight
testimonies page 28 the world is a
theatre the actors its inhabitants are
preparing to act their part in the last
great drama transgression has almost
reached its limit confusion fills the
world and a great terror is soon to come
upon human beings the end is very near
and we who know the truth should be
preparing for what is soon to break upon
the world as an overwhelming surprise we
who know the truth we have looked at
that and we've seen that the word truth
literally means in the Greek the
unfailing Verity of God's Word we who
know that he cannot lie we that have
have grown in faith trusting him should
be preparing Matthew chapter 24 tells us
and this is a common text this is a
common chapter most of us know this in
Matthew 24 the Lord says Jesus went out
and departed from the temple and his
disciples came to him to show him the
buildings of the temple this was one of
the most magnificent structures that had
ever been built and Herod had
refurbished the temple after the Hebrew
people had come back out of their
Babylonian captivity
jesus said unto them unto his disciples
see he not
all these things verily assuredly I say
unto you there shall not be left here
one stone upon another that shall not be
thrown down Jesus was speaking not only
of the destruction in AD 70 but I
believe we are yet to see a physical
manifestation of this prophecy because
if you go to Jerusalem today the Wailing
Wall is still there those stones that
are there have been there for 2,000
years there are still stones stacked one
upon another and right now in our world
we're seeing the focus on Israel but
what's more important than the physical
temple is the spiritual truth which it
was a shadow of which it was a symbol
which it represented desire of Ages page
162 161 we are told God designed that
the temple at Jerusalem should be a
continual witness to the high destiny
open to every soul but the Jews had not
understood the significance of the
building they regarded with so much
pride for they did not yield themselves
as holy temples for the divine spirit
that glorious building its walls of
glistening gold representing purity
purity and holiness reflecting in
rainbow hues the curtains that were in
wrought with cherubim the fragrance of
ever burning incense pervading the
entire building the priests robed in
spotless white and in the deep mystery
of the inner place above the mercy seat
between the figures of the bowed
worshipping angels was the
glory of the holiest the very presence
of the Living God in all these God
desired his people to read his purpose
for the human soul it was that same
purpose long afterwards set forth by the
Apostle Paul when speaking by the Holy
Spirit he said know ye not that you are
the temple of God and that the Holy
Spirit of God dwelleth in you and as
Jesus sat upon the Mount of Olives the
disciples came to him privately saying
when shall these things be and what
shall be the sign of thy coming and of
the end of the world jesus answered and
said unto them take heed that no man
deceive you for many shall come in my
name saying I am Christ and shall
deceive many and you shall hear of wars
and rumors of wars but see that you be
not troubled for all these things must
come to pass but the end is not yet for
many false prophets shall rise and shall
deceive many and because iniquity shall
abound do you remember what the Apostle
Paul said he said the mystery of
iniquity death already work the mystery
of how Satan takes possession of God's
temple by yielding to sin and
transgression because iniquity shall
abound the overspreading of abominations
is what the the prophet Daniel calls it
the love of many shall wax cold and this
gospel the glad tidings of the kingdom
shall be proclaimed in all the world
for a witness unto all nations and then
shall the income you know growing up as
a Christian I thought the kingdom is
Christ's second coming and I didn't
realize there is a deeper meaning when
you look up the word kingdom into Greek
it literally means the sovereign the
king and the reign of God he said this
glad tidings of the reign of God shall
be proclaimed in all the world as a
witness and then shall the income
galatians chapter 3 verse 8 and 9 listen
to what the apostle paul tells us and
the scripture foreseeing that God would
justify the heathen through faith
proclaimed before these glad tidings
even unto Abraham saying in thee and
later on in thy seed shall all nations
of the earth be blessed and we looked at
this the other night the word justify
literally means to declare and to render
just and innocent and clean and pure and
holy and righteous and perfect the
scripture foreseeing that God would
justify the heathen through faith that
the blessing of Abraham might come on
the Gentiles through Jesus Christ and
that we might receive the promise of the
Spirit through faith Galatians 3:14 says
it's interesting because
it says the blessing of Abraham might
come on the Gentiles the word come on
means to generate or to bring into being
Jesus went on and said when ye therefore
shall see the abomination which causes
desolation spoken of by Daniel the
prophet stand in the Holy Place whoso
readeth let him understand when you look
this verse up it says this abomination
that causes God's temple to be desolate
will stand in the Holy Place and the
word stand-in in Greek means to abide -
literally to covenant and abide then let
them which be in Judea flee into the
mountains for then shall be Great
Tribulation such as was not since the
world began no nor ever shall be
this was the focus of Christ's message
in Matthew 24 and in Luke 21 and in mark
13 the abomination that causes
desolation when the children of Israel
had went back and rebuilt the temple
after the Babylonian captivity we talked
about the other night
that when they built that temple the Ark
of the Covenant had been secret away
God's servant says and Josephus also
talks about that they indicate that it
was probably the Prophet Jeremiah that
instructed the priests to hide that Ark
of the Covenant that Ark was the throne
of God without the throne the King
cannot reign and now Christ tells us
when you see the abomination that causes
my temple
my sanctuary to be desolate you know
it's time to flee and God's Word says
that the temple that was desolate was
not just the physical temple it was
men's hearts
the prophet Daniel tells us in Daniel 9
now therefore o our God hear the prayer
of thy servant and my supplications let
thine anger and thy fury be turned away
from thy City Jerusalem a symbol of his
people from thy holy mountain and caused
thy face to shine upon thy sanctuary
which is desolate when Jesus went into
the temple in John chapter 2 many people
don't realise there was a veil between
the holy in the most holy place the holy
place was known as the tabernacle and
the tent of the congregation and the
most holy was the presence of God and
there was a veil that divided those two
but they don't realize that for almost
500 years there was nothing behind the
veil
they had a form of godliness but no
power Jesus went on and he inspired the
Apostle Paul and 2nd Thessalonians and
listen to what Paul says about this very
same event he says let no man deceive
you by any means for that day of
christ's return shall not come except
there come a falling away first an
apostasy and that man of sin be unmasked
and unveiled the son of perdition
the son of destruction who opposeth and
exalteth himself above all that is
called deity or God or that is
worshipped so that he as God is sitting
in the temple of God showing himself
that He is God there may be a physical
event that takes place in the Middle
East I'm not denying that but more
importantly Satan and his fallen angels
are going to strive to take possession
of the hearts and minds of every man
woman and child that has not surrendered
completely to Christ then Paul tells us
remember ye not that when I was yet with
you I told you these things but now you
know he that withholdeth he that is
holding back that he might be revealed
in his time for the mystery of iniquity
death already work when you look on the
screen and you look on the right hand
side that is the hexagram it's called
the Star of David by many people most
people don't realize that symbol was
never used in the Bible by God's
children Solomon there is record that he
possibly could have used that when he
had went into apostasy but what that
symbol means is even more striking it is
the union of a male and female triangle
one ascending and one descending it's
the same symbol that Hitler used when he
developed the symbol for the swastika or
when he adopted that symbol that was
actually a Hindu symbol and a Buddhist
symbol and we see that same philosophy
that same ideology with
symbol of the yen and Yong which you see
below it is the joining of opposites and
in the occult world as well as in
Eastern mysticism they tell you on the
higher levels it is the joining of
spirit and flesh the joining of what the
pagans say are the heavens and the earth
Revelation chapter 14 and 18 tells us
and they're followed another angel
saying Babylon is fallen is fallen and
she has become the she has made all
nations to drink of the wine of the
wrath of her fornication the word
fornication there means immorality and
the illicit union with pagan gods
revelation 18 goes on and gives us
another description of this he says the
Apostle John says after these things
after revelation 14 after the three
angels messages I saw another angel come
down from heaven having great power and
the earth was lightened with his glory
and he cried mightily with a loud cry
saying Babylon the Great is fallen is
fallen for she has become the habitation
of devils and the stronghold of every
foul spirit and a cage of every unclean
and hateful bird this is telling us that
when Christ returns every human being on
the face of the planet is either going
to be filled with the Spirit of the
Living God or they will be filled with
unclean and unholy spirits history is
repeating with the Bible open before
them and professing to reverence its
teachings
many of the religious leaders of our
time are destroying faith in the Bible
as the Word of God as the word of deity
we're told in Psalm 33 that by the word
of the Lord where the heavens made and
all the host of them by the breath of
his mouth that word has power jesus said
the words that I speak unto you they are
spirit and they are life when these men
destroy faith in God's Word they take
away from man and women the only thing
that has power to save them these men
busy themselves with dissecting the word
and they set their own opinions above
its plainness statements in their hands
God's Word loses its regenerating power
this is why infidelity runs riot and
iniquity is so widespread
when Satan has undermined faith in the
Bible he directs men to other sources
for light and power and thus through
these other sources he insinuates
himself
those who turn from the plain teaching
of Scripture and the convicting power of
God's Holy Spirit are inviting the
control of demons criticism and
speculation concerning the Scriptures
have opened the way for spiritism and
theosophy those modernized forms of
ancient hedonism to gain a foothold even
in the professed churches of our Lord
Jesus Christ now I want to show you how
this is happening in our day the men
that I am going to quote all of these
men are
part of the emergent church or emerging
church movement ancient mystical
practices that they are trying to blend
with Christianity and all of these men
are teachers in spiritual formation they
are using what we have been learning to
influence the congregations and millions
across this world this is a statement
from Professor Marcus Borg he was
professor at religion and culture at the
Oregon State University listen to what
he says enlightenment as an archetypal
and I may not be pronouncing that
correctly forgive me as an archetypal
religious metaphor belongs to a mystical
way of being religious outside of the
Jewish and Christian traditions the
best-known enlightenment experience is
the Buddha's mystical experience he's a
professor of religion and culture and
he's saying we need to look to the
Buddha to understand enlightenment and
then he says so it is in the Gospel of
John enlightenment is a central metaphor
for salvation and this is not true he
says to be enlightened is to be born
from above and of the spirit in other
words to be born again
thus the born-again experience according
to Professor Borg and John is an
enlightenment experience
now we need to look and see what this
enlightenment is obviously he's tracing
it back to the Buddha to the Buddhist
religion Shan claiborne
another Christian author and Christian
activist says if you tell me I have to
be born again in order to enter the
kingdom of God I can tell you that you
also have to say
everything you have and give it to the
poor because Jesus said that to one guy
also if Jesus said it can we not take
his word literally listen to what he
says but I guess that's why God invented
highlighters so that we can highlight
the parts we like and ignore the rest
this is identical to what Thomas
Jefferson did in the Jefferson Bible he
took the parts he liked and he cut out
the parts he didn't like he took out the
miracles of Christ he took out the
virgin birth he took out every statement
where Christ declared that he was the
son of God listen to what pastor Tony
Campolo said he said I learned about
this way of having a born-again
experience from reading the Catholic
mystics especially the Spiritual
Exercises of Ignatius Loyola Ignatius
Loyola was the founder of the Jesuit
movement he was heavily involved in
eastern mysticism his book the Spiritual
Exercises is now being used across the
rest Western world by yoga instructors
and gurus and Taichi and ki gong
instructors they have found that by
using what Ignatius taught they can
enhance the practice of their Eastern
arts like most Catholic mystics he
developed an intense desire to
experience a oneness with God
gradually he came to feel an intense
yearning for the kind of spiritual
purity that he believed would enable him
to experience the fullness of God's
presence within another leader Brian
McLaren he said from this is from his
new book a new kind of Christianity when
Jesus promises life of the ages a far
better translation of the Greek I
believe than eternal life he is not
promising life after death or life in
eternal heaven instead of eternal hell
being born of God and born again or
being born from above would in this
light mean being born into this new
creation
so again Jesus is offering a life in the
new Genesis a new creation that is of
the ages what he just did was he twisted
the Word of God he made it so
complicated Jesus said I have given unto
you eternal life our Father said I have
given unto you eternal life and this
life is in my son it means literally you
will live forever what Brian McLaren
just said was almost the exact same
thing that Pastor Rick Warren is
teaching in The Purpose Driven Life
don't worry about heaven and hell it's
about here and now ministry of healing
page 429 we are told these theories that
God resides in all matter or pantheism
if they are followed to their logical
conclusion they sweep away the entire
Christian economy the plan of salvation
they do away with the necessity for the
atonement the at one month of man with
God and they make man his own Savior
these theories regarding God make his
word of none effect and those who accept
them are in great
danger of being finally led to look upon
the whole Bible as a fiction they may
regard virtue as being better than vice
but God being removed from his position
of sovereignty the throne of our heart
they place their dependence upon human
power alone which without God is
worthless now I want to show you
something a little more up-to-date
listen to what happened at an interview
in 1988 Barbara Walters held an
interview with George HW Bush George
Bush Senior when he was on his campaign
trail for the presidency and she asked
him a question that completely caught
him off guard she asked the the upcoming
new president of our nation if he was a
Christian because there were things he
was saying that were causing the
Christians in America to say finally
we've got a Christian president this is
a good thing and she wanted to make this
clear in her interview when she asked if
he was a Christian listen to what George
Bush senior said he stumbled over his
words he looked down for a moment and
then he answered if by being a Christian
you asked if I'm born again then yes I
am a Christian what many don't realize
is that George Bush Senior George Bush
jr. and Prescott Bush the grandfather
were all members of an occult society at
Yale University that society was called
the Skull and Bones and in their
initiation they went through a ritual
that once it was achieved you were
classified as a man that had been twice
born manly P Hall one of the the
greatest philosophers of Freemasonry
that they've ever had
listen to what he says among the
ancients a fabulous bird called the
Phoenix is described by early riders in
size and shape it resembles the eagle
but with certain differences the Phoenix
it is said lives for 500 years and at
its death its body opens and there's
this flame of fire and out of the ashes
emerges a new Phoenix because of this
symbolism the Phoenix is generally
regarded as representing immortality and
resurrection in the Chinese arts and
that's where they got it from you
usually see two symbols that are held
higher than all others the Dragon and
the Phoenix and often you will see the
two intertwined
it means the dragon is the symbol of
occult wisdom and the Phoenix is the
symbol of rebirth
so through occult wisdom and initiation
they believe that a man can be reborn
Manley P Hall went on to say the Phoenix
is one sign of the secret orders of the
ancient world and of the initiate of
those orders for it was common to refer
to one who had been accepted into the
temples as a man twice born or reborn
wisdom confers a new life and those who
become wise are said to be born again do
you know this is the same thing that
Satan said to Eve
it's a tree that will make you wise and
the Apostle James says this wisdom
descendeth not from above but from
beneath General Albert Pike he was a
Confederate Civil War general
he wrote the Bible for Freemasonry
called morals and Dogma listen to what
he says in that book initiation was
considered to be a mystical death and
the perfect initiate in the aleutian
mysteries was then said to be
regenerated new born and restored to a
renovated existence of life light and
purity
the Bible says professing themselves to
be wise they become dumb in the ancient
system of initiation the truth seeker
must pass through a second birth and
those who attain this exalted state were
known thereafter as twice born this new
birth must be personally earned through
a complete regeneration of character and
conduct now I want you to pay attention
to his words this new birth must be
personally earned you earn wages God's
Word tells us that the new birth is a
gift from God
you cannot do anything to earn
perfection and righteousness this new
birth he says the ceremony involves a
symbolic death according to Kenneth
Mackenzie who is another Masonic author
he writes in the ancient mysteries the
aspirant could not participate in the
highest secrets until they had been
placed in a coffin in this ceremony
he was then symbolically said to die and
his resurrection was to the light
Albert Pike goes on and says the day has
come when fellow craftsmen must know and
apply their knowledge the lost key to
their grade is the mastery of emotion
when I was in Chinese kung fu and Enki
Gong and in Tai Chi all of those arts
focused on channeling emotion because
Satan knows the emotions are the easiest
doorway to find access to the throne of
your heart he says once they have
achieved mastery of their emotions it
places the energy of the universe at
their disposal when the Mason learns
that the key to the warrior on the block
is the proper application of the Dynamo
of living power then he has learned the
mystery of his craft you remember what
Paul said the mystery of iniquity Satan
works to control our emotions we know
that faith is not based on emotions
faith is based on thus saith the Lord
regardless of how I feel I have to take
God's word and say this is sure he
cannot lie but the occult world says
it's all based on emotions
he says the seething energies of Lucifer
of Lucifer are then in his hands and
before he may step onward and upward he
must prove his ability to properly apply
this energy when I was in Chinese kung
fu and I was working on on discipleship
level that was the one thing that we had
to do we were told we have to channel
this energy that they called Chi
into our hands and into our arms and
move it in the body and then we had to
demonstrate we were we were able to do
that some people would demonstrate that
through breaking you know cinder blocks
or stones some people would demonstrate
it through breaking coconuts with their
palm other people would demonstrate it
like the other man and I we had to be
able to take our hand and make the hand
get hot and the other one freezing cold
and then we were told make the pointer
finger get hot the rest of the hand
freezing cold once we had done that we
began practicing with channeling that
energy into the hand when we would
strike but all of this were gifts that
were given to us by the spirits that had
come into our lives Albert Pike says he
must follow in the footsteps of his
forefather tubal-cain he was one of the
offspring of Cain in Genesis who with
the mighty strength of the war God
hammered his sword into a sword into a
plowshare
incessant vigilance over thought action
and desire is indispensable to those who
wish to make progress in the unfolding
or unveiling of their own being they are
showing like they did in that previous
slide this figure from the Freemasons is
showing a Mason with a hammer and a
chisel cutting himself out of the stone
God's Word says that Christ was the
stone that was cut out of the mountain
without hands and that we also are
living stones cut and chiseled without
hands but by the power of God once this
progress has been made in the
folding of their own being he says the
fellow crafts degree is the degree of
transmutation that's another word for
transformation the changing of the
character that we were designed to be
the image that we were designed to be
into the image of Lucifer and Satan now
look where all this goes back to New
World Encyclopedia tells us in Hinduism
the highest three classes of Hindu
society are known as the visa that means
in Hindu Sanskrit the twice-born ones
because they have undergone the sacred
thread ceremony in which male members
are initiated into the second stage of
life called the Ashrama
of a Vedic follower this sacred thread
ceremony is considered to be a type of
second birth the doctrine of the
twice-born
has been criticized for promoting
hierarchy and elitism in Hindu society
but its supporters see it as a type of
initiation and purification into a
higher state of existence and now Gois
analog forgive me I can't even pronounce
that and a longest to the baptism of
other religions the British key society
it says Zen Buddhism began the idea of
understanding life it suggests that when
one understands life one feels as if one
is newly born that's where the word
sensei comes from that's what a Japanese
master instructor is called a
say he says the word sin means before
and say means to be born so since a
literally means a person who is twice
born or born before this birth is a
spiritual not physical birth people tell
me all the time aren't martial arts just
about self-defense that's what Satan
wants you to think when you begin isn't
yoga just about stretching that's what
the serpent the Kundalini as they call
him in yoga that's what he wants you to
believe when you begin but the Masters
will tell you the gurus will tell you
this birth is a spiritual not a physical
birth the original meaning of sensei is
one who is spiritually born before
others desire of Ages page 35
Satan was seeking to shut out from men a
knowledge or knowing of God and to turn
their attention from the temple of God
and to establish his own Kingdom through
hedonism Satan won his great triumph in
perverting the faith of Israel by
contemplating and worshiping their own
conceptions the heathen had lost a
knowledge of God and had become more and
more corrupt and so it was with ancient
Israel the principle that man can save
himself by his own works lay at the
foundation of every heathen religion it
had now become the principle of the
Jewish religion Satan had implanted this
principle and wherever it is held men
have no barrier against sin we need to
ask our
elves as Christians and even it more
importantly as seventh-day Adventist
Christians are we following the
footsteps of the ancient Jewish people
are we striving to earn salvation and to
set ourselves free from sin through our
own will and works the means by which we
can overcome the wicked one is that by
which Christ overcame by the power of
the word the same word that spoke light
in the darkness spoke life to the dead
it spoke purity to Mary Magdalene it
spoke wholeness to the leper in Luke
chapter 5 God does not control our minds
without our consent but if we desire to
know and to do his will he has promised
we shall know the truth and the truth
shall make us free the world is a
theatre the actors are its inhabitants
they are preparing to act their part in
the last great drama with the great
masses of mankind there is no unity
except as men Confederate to accomplish
their selfish purposes and God is
looking on a power from beneath is
working to bring about the last great
scenes of the drama Satan coming as
Christ and working with all
deceivableness of unrighteousness in
those who are binding themselves
together in these secret societies the
forces of darkness will unite with human
agents who have given themselves into
the control of Satan and the same scenes
that were exhibited at the trial
rejection and crucifixion of Christ
Jesus
we'll be revived again through yielding
to satanic influences men will be
transformed into fiends look that word
up and those who were created in the
image of God who were formed to honor
and to glorify our Creator will become
the habitation of dragons and Satan will
see in an apostate race his masterpiece
of evil men who reflect his own image
transgression has almost reached its
limit confusion fills the world and a
great terror is soon to come upon human
beings the end is very near and we who
know the truth should be preparing for
what is soon to break upon this world as
an overwhelming surprise Jesus told us
when Satan appears don't even go and
look don't cut your television on to see
because it will be an overmastering
delusion and I saw another angel fly in
the midst of heaven having the
everlasting gospel in glad tidings to
proclaim to them that dwell on the earth
to every nation and kindred and tongue
and people and listen to what he says
with a loud voice he cries and says fear
God and give the glory to him for the
hour of his judgment has come and
worship Him that made heaven and earth
and sea and the fountains of water this
is the Sabbath it is a sign that we have
faith that the same word that brought
world's and the universe into existence
is able to recreate you and I in the
image of our Savior let everyone who
claims to believe that the Lord is soon
coming search the Scriptures as never
before
for Satan is determined to try every
device possible to keep souls in
darkness and blind their minds to the
perils of the times in which we are now
living let every believer take up his
Bible with earnest prayer that he may be
enlightened by the Holy Spirit as to
what his truth what is the unfailing
Verity of God's Word that he may know
more of God and of Jesus Christ whom he
has sent
search for the truth as for hidden
treasures and disappoint our enemy the
time of test is just upon us she says
for the loud cry of the third angel has
already begun to sound in the revelation
and revealing of the righteousness of
Christ as our sin pardoning Redeemer
this is the beginning of the light of
the angel whose glory will fill the
whole earth if you would stand through
the time of trouble the Lord's servant
tells us you must know Christ for this
is life eternal and appropriate as your
own the gift of his righteousness which
he imputes to the repentant sinner first
selected messages page 363 the message
of Christ's righteousness is to sound
from one end of the earth to the other
to prepare the way for our king this is
the glory of God which closes the work
of the third angel
then she says in testimonies to
ministers page 456 what is justification
by faith it is the work of God in laying
the glory of man in the dust and doing
for you and I that which it is not in
our power to do for ourselves Luke 17
listen to what our Savior says and when
Jesus was demanded by the Pharisees when
the kingdom of God should come he
answered and said unto them the kingdom
of God
the reign and the sovereign of God
cometh not with observation neither
shall they say lo here or lo there for
behold the kingdom the reign of God is
within you
Nicodemus came to Jesus and he asked the
same question and jesus answered and
said unto him except a man be born again
begotten again he cannot see the kingdom
of God and Nicodemus asked how can these
things be jesus answered that which is
born of the flesh is just flesh but that
which is born by the Spirit of God is
spirit Marvel not that I say unto you
you must be born again now I want to
look in our last moments I want us to
see how this happens Galatians chapter 3
verse 1 through 3 the Apostle Paul tells
us o foolish Galatians who hath
bewitched you that you should not obey
the truth and you look up the word obey
it means have confidence in and believe
who has bewitched you that you do not
believe the Word of God before whose
eyes Jesus Christ hath been evidently
set forth and before ordained crucified
for you are you so foolish having begun
by the spirit are you now made perfect
by the flesh do you remember how Isaac
was born God came to Abraham and Sarah
and he said Ishmael who you had by the
power of the flesh he's not even counted
as seed of your own flesh you're gonna
bear a son God promised Abraham and
Sarah would have that son and Galatians
4 says that's why Isaac was born by the
spirit for as many as received him John
says to them gave he power to become to
be brought into being as the sons and
daughters of God even to them that
believe on his name John 1 verse 12 and
13 which are born or begotten not by
blood nor by the will of the flesh nor
by the will of man but of God
for of his own will begat he us with the
word of truth so that we should be a
kind of firstfruits of his creatures his
creation James 1 verse 18 through 21
tells us and then Galatians says now we
brethren Galatians 4 28 and 29 now we
brethren
as Isaac was our children of God by
promise but just as it was then he that
was born by the flesh persecuted him
that was born by the spirit even so it
is now do you remember what happened in
1888 the majority of God's leaders and
the majority of our church rejected the
message that Christ had given through
Jones and Waggoner they said were doing
this fine on our own
they repeated what the children of
Israel had said at Mount Sinai the Lord
came down and spoke his Commandments his
laws of life and they said everything
you've said we will do Ellen White says
every command is a promise and God says
all that I have spoken I will do for it
is I that work in you both to will and
to do that which pleases me first Peter
chapter 1 verse 22 and 23 says therefore
being born and begotten again not of
corruptible seed but of incorruptible by
the Word of God which liveth and abideth
for ever and this is the word which by
the glad tidings
it's proclaimed unto you behold brothers
and sisters what manner of love the
father hath bestowed upon us that we
should be called the sons of God it is
for this reason that the world knoweth
us not because it knew him not beloved
now today if you will but hear my voice
and harden not your hearts and unbelief
now are we the sons and daughters of God
and it does not appear what we shall be
but we know that when he appears we
shall be like him for we shall see him
as he is
[Music]